we will establish a Truth and
Reconciliation Commission wow to
declassify and publish all documents on
deep State spying censorship and
Corruption and there are plenty of them
right fifth we will launch a major
Crackdown on government leakers who
collude with the fake news to
deliberately we false narratives Now
understand that's a Crackdown on
whistleblowers Trump calls them false
leakers but in many of these cases we're
talking about whistleblowers and Trump
clearly wants to go after not only the
Whistleblower but the media Outlets that
publish the stuff as well the
journalists as well completely attacking
overtly journalism as an institution